sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales del
programa de france 24 que los invita a
dar una vuelta al mundo de la mano de
nuestra red de periodistas la guerra
sigue devastando el este de ucrania con
la provincia de lucanas como principal
foco de los combates las tropas rusas
destruyeron todos los puentes que
conectaban la ciudad de severodonezk
haciendo imposible la evacuación de
civiles así como la entrada de ayudas
humanitarias
moscú sigue asegurando que su principal
objetivo es la protección de las
autoproclamadas repúblicas de danielle y
lugares cuya independencia reconoce esto
a pesar de la presencia de las tropas de
moscú en el sur del país y el continuo
bloqueo de los puertos ucranianos en el
mar negro sin embargo con una mayor
calma en otras partes de ucrania más de
dos millones de personas han decidido
regresar al país a pesar de esto las
autoridades piden calma porque el
conflicto continúa y rusia sigue
atacando con misiles en otras partes del
país el siguiente es un reporte de irene
sabio y letizia al preso
no es una decisión fácil de tomar en los
andenes de la estación del idif en el
oeste del país muchas familias y jóvenes
parejas esperan un tren para poder
volver a su hogar en ciudades como kiev
marina tiene 27 años y es de quiero cuyo
las primeras semanas de la guerra pero
tras pasaron unos meses en libia decidió
volver a su casa para esta joven no hay
ningún lugar seguro en ucrania así que
prefiere estar cerca de su familia
y
nos fuimos al y mi marido y yo porque
mis padres se quedaron en kiev estuvimos
ahí unos dos meses en casa de un amigo
porque era muy difícil encontrar y
alquilar un apartamento así que hace un
mes el 31 de mayo volvimos y hoy sólo
fuimos salir por un día
su madre natalia tiene sentimientos
encontrados por la vuelta de su hija
por una parte me gustaría que ellos
estuvieran lejos de la guerra pero por
otra parte los misiles vuelan por toda
ucrania y pueden ir a todos los sitios
kiev live o deza cerca de 30 mil
ucranianos cruzan la frontera para
volver a sus casas a pesar de la guerra
según la oficina fronteriza y lo hacen
en trenes como éste recorren cientos de
kilómetros con mucho miedo por los
bombardeos pero también con mucha
ilusión de poder volver a sus casas
elena estés en ccoo acaba de volver de
bélgica donde estaba su familia viaja
con su marido a kiev para poder recoger
ropa y visitar a familiares y amigos en
sus 5
vamos a estar en kiev unas dos o tres
semanas depende de la situación y
depende de cómo esté todo en kiev de los
ataques con misiles
y
el deseo de volver a recuperar sus vidas
hace que muchos ucranianos tomen el
camino de vuelta a su hogar
el gobierno alemán planea entregar visas
de larga duración a periodistas y
disidentes rusos eso facilitaría que los
rusos en el exilio retomen el trabajo en
alemania actualmente sólo cuentan con
visa schengen de corto plazo y a
diferencia de los refugiados ucranianos
no pueden trabajar uno de ellos es maxim
crónico editor en jefe de la prestigiosa
emisora eco de moscú ahora fuera del
aire el siguiente es un informe de anima
y william área en expansión
desde que llegaron a berlín máximo
crónico firmas llamada years han tenido
una sola meta devolverle la vida a ecos
de moscú la forma de emisoras de radio
sacada del aire por el kremlin por su
cobertura de la guerra en ucrania pero
como muchos periodistas independientes
salieron de rusia con una visa schengen
que no les da derecho a trabajar en
alemania así que llevan tres meses
esperando por una solución
ni siquiera podemos tener una cuenta
bancaria propia o crear una compañía
porque no tenemos oportunidad de hacerlo
y por eso es todo tan lento pero
esperamos que cuando tengamos la otra
visa sea más sencillo
[Música]
hay unos 70 periodistas rusos en el
exilio en alemania que los próximos días
deberían recibir visas de larga duración
el gobierno alemán también destinará 3
millones y medio de euros para ayudar a
periodistas y figuras de la oposición
rusa en el exilio en el curso del
próximo año tres meses después de que
estallara la guerra es una solución
satisfactoria aunque lenta en llegar de
acuerdo con el eurodiputado sergei lago
de esquí
[Música]
todas estas personas representan el
rostro de una rusia mejor y más
democrática una rusia que queremos
ayudar a construir en el futuro
a
periodistas y disidentes que permanecen
en rusia u otros países podrían pedir
una visa humanitaria para irse a
alemania pero a diferencia de los
ucranianos sus casos serán analizados
uno por uno una distinción que amnistía
internacional considera injusta
hablamos de gente con la que miembros de
nuestro gobierno han tenido contacto
regular en el pasado así que no entiendo
por qué no podemos encontrar una
solución global para un grupo de
personas que no es tan grande
maxim corn y coffee marcha myers todavía
confían en que el plan del gobierno
ayude a otros periodistas rusos a irse a
berlín para fortalecer su equipo echo de
moscú regresará a través de streaming en
internet al final del verano
y ahora pasamos a costa de márfil en
áfrica occidental donde más de 800.000
niños trabajan en las plantaciones de
cacao según un estudio de la universidad
de chicago realizado en el año 2019 más
de 2000 de ellos han sido retirados de
los campos y llevados a centros para
luego ser enviados a la escuela sin
embargo el tráfico y la explotación de
menores sigue siendo una realidad en el
país muchos de ellos proceden de países
vecinos como burkina faso o mal y el
siguiente es un informe de samuel bernés
situada a 300 km al oeste de abiyán la
región de nagua es una de las mayores
zonas agrícolas de costa de marfil
también uno de los territorios más
afectados por el trabajo infantil hoy
xabi tiene 18 años nunca fue a la
escuela porque su abuela la cuidaba en
el campo cuando nuestros amigos iban a
la escuela ella quería que fuéramos pero
no podía permitírselo
al igual que xavi el 90% de los casos de
trabajo infantil se producen en el seno
de la familia y suelen suponer el
abandono de la escuela pero en este
centro dedicado a la acogida de niños
víctimas de la trata o del trabajo
forzado también hay muchos niños de
países vecinos fatal un chico de 15 años
de burkina faso fue recogido en un campo
de cacao hace una semana
falta o no es víctima del trabajo
forzado sino de la trata de personas
desde burkina una red organizada lo
llevó a costa de marfil
de los burkineses los malienses cuando
tienen un hijo en costa de marfil para
ellos es algo seguro
todo el mundo quiere tener un hijo aquí
con un producto como el cacao que atrae
a todo el mundo al título con el cacao
representa el 14 por ciento del producto
interno bruto de costa de marfil es la
actividad más afectada por el trabajo
infantil en el país por lo tanto es en
las aldeas de los plantadores donde
tratan de concientizar a los adultos
esta brigada contra el trabajo infantil
viene a reunirse con el jefe del pueblo
para transmitir un mensaje sencillo al
dirigirse a los líderes de la comunidad
la brigada espera a llegar a todo el
pueblo
pueden ser nuestros reemplazos el jefe
está ahí es también tiene reuniones voy
a hablar con los que pueden ser reacios
para mostrarle los beneficios de lo que
hace según las últimas estimaciones para
2019 15 millones de menores trabajaban
en el sector del cacao en costa de
marfil y ghana
aquí no es uno de los alimentos más
completos del mundo y tuvo en bolivia
una época dorada de costos elevados que
parece haber llegado a su fin en la
actualidad más de 70 mil productores se
ven afectados por el desplome de los
precios la razón de esta caída es que
cada vez más países producen el grano
compitiendo con la producción de un país
que solía ser uno de los principales
exportadores el siguiente es un informe
de meriva k
[Música]
el remoto origen de la quinua que posee
muchas virtudes nutricionales está en
las riberas del lago titicaca desde hace
siglos agricultores como los aymaras
ismael cruz y margarita zárate cultivan
este alimento rico en proteínas
aminoácidos vitaminas y minerales
que no es más alimento para nuestro
cuerpo para nuestro cuerpo al que sea
fuerte
para que no nos hagas de las
enfermedades
ismael y margarita cultivan la quinua
para su consumo pero no han logrado
desarrollar sus plantaciones por falta
de tierras en cambio los productores de
las regiones sureñas de potosí y oruro
tienen una planta industrial para
procesar y exportar la variedad de
quinoa real orgánica la que consideran
la más nutritiva del mundo
este producto es exportado a europa con
los sellos respectivos para la
producción orgánica también a eeuu sin
embargo los precios se han desplomado
porque el número de países productores
de quinua ha pasado de 20 a más de 100
aunque la exportación de quinoa
representa muy poco porcentaje de las
ventas de bolivia y no parece afectar su
economía
70.000 campesinos si están sufriendo por
no recuperar sus costos de producción el
gobierno les ha ofrecido apoyo para
ingresar a nuevos mercados
pueden a ver si el país esté produciendo
la quinoa lo vamos a alcanzar a la
demanda internacional
ahora hay que trabajar en eso para que
nosotros
y tengamos un
un valor adicional pues por ser el país
de origen
mientras tanto y como hace siglos los
indígenas de las riberas del lago
titicaca siguen produciendo para sí
mismos el alimento más poderoso de los
andes' ajenos a los vaivenes del mercado
internacional
en singapur el aumento del nivel del mar
hace temer por el futuro de la ciudad de
estado y sus 6 millones de habitantes el
primer ministro lee hsien loong ha hecho
de la lucha contra este problema una
prioridad y desde el 2019 su gobierno ha
creado una unidad compuesta por unos 40
expertos en calentamiento global que
están desarrollando soluciones
innovadoras con miras a contrarrestar
los efectos de esta subida la siguiente
es un informe de ellos tema care y
marina lópez y hay una popurrí
singapur es modesto en tamaño pero
cuenta con una historia de gran éxito
económico uno de los países más ricos
del mundo pero es también uno de los más
amenazados android
margets bajo los objetivos de emisiones
podemos llegar a 90 centímetros y hay
una probabilidad muy baja de que debido
a que no entendemos las capas de hielo
de la antártida picasso fernand están de
antártico hay 6
tal vez se eleve en realidad a
aproximadamente 17 metros es mi altura
meters ayer tener ese trayecto
esto es hay 2000
detrás de la sonrisa hay una
preocupación muy real por el futuro las
lluvias torrenciales en marea alta
unidas al aumento del nivel del mar han
hecho que la ciudad de estado se ve
afectada por devastadoras inundaciones
repentinas en los últimos años como
muestra esta animación the strait times
el nivel de las aguas podría subir 5
metros en el peor de los casos y
sumergir parte de los emblemáticos
muelles de singapur
es muy aterrador y da mucho miedo sin
duda este es uno de los lugares más
hermosos y también lo llamo hogar
de una especie de pánico al mismo tiempo
crea mucha responsabilidad de nosotros
sobre cómo contribuimos a evitar que
este desastre llegue en el futuro amén
pero singapur se defiende ha destinado
al menos 70 mil millones de euros para
hacer frente al cambio climático en los
próximos 50 a 100 años
formas de potasio para nosotros la
protección del litoral es una amenaza
existencial porque el 30 por ciento del
territorio en singapur no está a más de
5 metros sobre el nivel del mar casi un
tercio de la isla está amenazada por las
inundaciones
esta ley es parte de la solución pasa
por los diques vertical los diques de
contención y las compuertas de marea los
proyectos de recuperación de tierras
deben estar al menos cuatro metros por
encima del nivel medio del mar uno más
que antes los costes son elevados pero
singapur está decidida a convertirse en
pionera en la lucha contra la crisis
climática
queremos agradecer a casa arsenal por
prestarnos sus instalaciones para la
realización de este programa y ustedes
también muchas gracias por seguir un
nuevo episodio de corresponsales nos
damos cita la próxima semana sigan con
más información en france 24 y zonas 24
puntos
[Aplausos]